it's just draining out my nose is that
normal
is that
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we welcome
drew barrymore to the hot seat
she's the golden globe award-winning
actress you know from films like the
wedding singer e.t
charlie's angels and many more these
days you can catch on netflix's santa
clarita diet and hosting the drew
barrymore show which is set to premiere
on cbs september 14th
drew barrymore welcome to the show thank
you for having me
before we get started i want to
compliment your team the way you guys
have recreated the hot ones experience
right down to the red napkins
i just want to say i'm humbled i'm blown
away looking at it
well first of all you deserve nothing
less um
as does the show and i
i know that if i'm watching it i want to
be in that environment so let's be
transportive
and take people with us
[Music]
what's this on the scoville scale nice
and easy like 1800 scoville like very
much sort of the table sauce
yeah i know
i'm gonna be fine for a while and then
not
so recently you teased the premiere of
the drew barrymore show by interviewing
keenan thompson and kel mitchell
the two stars of the cult classic film
good
burger the three of you share in common
the unique experience of navigating big
screen hollywood as kids
do you feel a kinship towards those
particular actors who've gone down that
road and come out the other side
i was talking to um my daughters and
their cousins i had like a clown car of
kids
this weekend and we were talking about
a lot of these people who grow up in the
industry and i said you know the thing
that you have to realize is
how hard it is to grow up at all let
alone in front of everybody
people who can create longevity from
being a kid
into going an adult while doing it with
no boundaries it's an art but
anyone who can figure out how to
navigate it
no matter what that journey looks like
if at some point they
grow into themselves and there is any
form of grace there
it's it's a big kudos
these uh wings are delicious by the way
i can get down with a mock chicken any
day
this is good so you've been acting since
you're 11 months old and over the years
have appeared in more than 70 tv shows
and movies so here what we want to do is
just
fact check some of the folklore
surrounding your biggest roles
fact or fiction you're supposed to be
the main lead in scream but
fought to take a character who was
killed in the first 12 minutes as a way
to kind of like goof on the audience
okay so in the horror film genre my
biggest
pet peeve was that i always knew the
main character was gonna be like
slugging through at the end but was
gonna like
creak by and make it and
that's the art of great filmmaking that
even if you know that you're still like
oh
god what i wanted to do is to
take that comfort zone away so i asked
if i could be
casey becker so that we would
establish that that rule does not apply
in this film
fact or fiction and the lead up to
charlie's angels you cameron diaz and
lucy liu had to do a 40-mile
survival hike as part of the training
i mean i literally almost lost my two
dearest friends um
for the press tour marie claire magazine
was like i know
can we send you to outward bound for
three days
and of course the producer side of me
was like yeah yeah yeah that's a great
idea that's fresh that's different
we just got set out in the middle of
nowhere no blankets no
food three days in i lost my mind
and my girlfriends are like we don't
even want to talk to you
right now and i just slumped in a corner
and i came back
around at the end and they kindly
received me but
i got put out like dino at the end of
flintstones
is it true that your grandfather's body
was stolen from the morgue by w.c
fields errol flynn and satakachi hartman
so that they could prop him up against a
poker table and throw one last party
with the guy
not only yes but there have been
like cinematic interpretations of that
a blake edwards film called sob that's
just brilliant and fun to watch no
matter what
and then i've heard things about weekend
at bernie's i can't know
ever if that's even true but yes they
did
and i will say this i hope my friends do
the same for me
that is the kind of spirit i can get
behind just
prop the old bag up let's have a few
last rounds
and i think death comes with
so much morose sadness
and i understand that but if it's okay
just for me if everybody could be really
happy
and celebratory and have a party that
would be my preference
i love the taste of this one the
scoville scale in my mouth
wilbur scoville 1912 0 right here
fine so it wouldn't be a first we feast
production if we didn't get extremely
granular about your food preferences
when you think back on all the movies
that you've done
which one had the best craft service
home fries
no ironically it was the two charlie's
angels movies
and the reason i say that and santa
clarita diet
because my favorite craft services are
the ones that have the little mini
sandwich making area and you just have a
little stack of bread
and some lettuce and some pre-cut
tomatoes and some sliced cheese
give me a sandwich bar any day and i'm
just so happy
and then on santa clarita diet you know
you're like a zombie eating just like
what looks like gray meats and stuff
does that food taste disgusting is it
good what is that
so one time it was that a raw chicken
leg and it was cake when i bit
into it so it really kept it interesting
i never knew what i was gonna get
because they were always trying to
like hit some mark because i don't think
i'm a good
actor i like the genuine moments and
sheila
delighted in the human meat so much that
it made my job
so real because i always was having so
much fun with it
oh god i love sheila hammond so much she
brought me back to life in so many ways
oh all right
[Music]
i'm i just felt such tremendous
relief and i just realized in that
moment oh there's
there's where i'm an idiot i've used
this analogy before but sometimes like
professional wrestlers they get cocky
and then they get the chair
smashed over their heads you know the
chair's coming
so we interview actors all the time but
it's rare to talk to somebody with their
hands and as many honey pots as you have
from the producing and directing credits
to of course your production company
alongside nancy juvenine
when you think about the fundamental
ways that movies have changed over the
years
what are some of the things that stand
out you know i know et for example was a
movie that was shot in sequence but
that's kind of a thing of the past
that was again stephen just
is the greatest genius there is nothing
more irritating
actually that's a hyperbolic statement
that doesn't apply to
this world at all it's difficult and
challenging when
you care very much about your job and
you want to do a good job
life is a journey and we just don't know
things until we know things
and a lot of the time films will shoot
the last scene of the movie
right up front because of budgetary
reasons
shooting in sequence was the greatest
luxury with et and it's just not really
a realistic thing
in the industry but i do think the
biggest change
in the industry is the amount of movies
that come out
the type of movies that can survive at a
box office
now are not the same type of movies that
used to come out mostly comedies
romantic comedies
you really have to have the expectations
of like tentpole
comic book movies but there's so much
great
storytelling now so as long as it's rich
in that
then bring it on and put it anywhere and
everybody comes to play because what
we all want watching it is relatability
entertainment
escapism education
something to fall into so if it's good i
don't really care
where it is i just want to get lost in
it
oh the gram is coming
i mean i'm not chinsing here either
very impressed from this side of the
zoom
um i didn't want to be a [ __ ] and just
like
you know all right true we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that grammar do a deep dive on
our guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context
what do you remember about presenting an
et
doll to princess diana i remember it
so well i actually have a series of
pictures from this and you can see
stephen in that picture watching me like
a hawk and i didn't have
a dad you know growing up so
he really was that father figure for me
and i just latched right on like koala
the eucalyptus tree
and he was explaining like make sure you
present the doll
to her there was a curtsy and
i just for a seven-year-old little girl
to be meeting not only a princess but
princess diana
it's like living in a fantasy
where does rushing the field at fenway
park in front of a sold
out crowd rank amongst maybe the wildest
scenes that you've ever had to shoot for
movies another fantasy
i also had to drop down from the green
monster and i slipped and i
smashed my disc so i wasn't very
comfortable
but i mean you know hey
give a disc for fenway any day but the
red sox
started winning it just was this wild
moment that we got to experience in
history
and keep filming right there on the
field including the winning game
it was like a front row seat to history
you've done three box office shattering
rom-coms with adam sandler
how early on did you recognize your
unique chemistry
i just i wanted to be a pair i loved
what he'd put out in the world
there aren't a ton of men who have this
sort of clean
cut good person thing that guys are
really into
and girls love and they're just awesome
comedians
and their humor isn't mean-spirited or
overly dirty but it's not
like so clean and sanitized
he hit every mark for me and i thought
if i could get on a magic carpet with
this gentleman
i'm convinced we could go places
i just have this admiration and
adoration and i
pretend it's an in love thing but it's
really just a love thing
and i have it with him and for him and
so i thought can we do something with
this
i can't like sit on this anymore i love
you
the reaper
very smoky you can taste like the the
burnt chili in that one as action
bronson would say
i am starting to shfitz a little bit
like it's coming out the pores
you're a member of saturday night live's
exclusive five-timer club and hold the
title as the youngest person
ever to host doing a show alongside the
likes of eddie murphy and a young julia
louis-dreyfus when you're just seven
years old
saturday night live is a very big
training ground for me
it's just a really like 360 kind of
experience
and they're changing the dialogue on you
at the last second i don't like to look
at the cue cards i like to try and
memorize everything
so that if something goes wrong and it's
live that i'm not
using a crutch but they're changing
stuff on you to the last minute and it
gets
so challenging that's fear saturday
night live
is terrifying and i love it because when
you're afraid it means you haven't done
it before
you're not confident and you are in this
zone
and that's where i prefer to be as sick
and masochistic as it is
i love it i i have to admit
i was worried what if i couldn't make it
through and by the way i don't know
why i'm saying that now oh that was
it i just did it i just screwed myself
i think you'll be fine but you know
overall i think i see you know people
come into the show
and and there is like a natural sort of
nervousness that happens with guests you
know because
you're really kind of stuck on the show
with me in front of all these like
scorching hot sauces and wings and then
you got cameras on you like you can't
escape like once you do someone's show
you can't escape you're like you're
tethered here you're stuck
awesome is it that you found a format to
make people nervous squeal with delight
want to come on and test themselves be a
part of this party you started
i'm that is no easy feat
hottest one so far it's really
interesting it's
where i seem to be experiencing the most
side effects of this is just out my skin
yeah it can kind of squeeze you like a
sponge i've said that before you can
kind of like
sweat in places you didn't know you had
yeah it's all here
but be careful around there you know yes
i know i keep touching it
gosh i know better i've heard you say
that you have special admiration for
entertainers who are chameleon-like in
their appearance
as someone who was once the face of
cover girl who are the people that stand
out to you as trailblazers from a
presentation perspective i
uh i
i okay
i
[Music]
i love when madonna lady gaga
barbra streisand david bowie people
would come out
and i never knew what they were gonna
look like that time and i would wait
with great
anticipation of what their next act was
but like when lady gaga came out as a
guy at the grammys
i just fell over i was like yes this
is the type of thing i am craving and
i'm looking for it was the most
unexpected thing for her to do
and this is a woman who came out in meat
dresses um and inside
of bizarre eggs with you know roman
soldiers carrying her
but it's not shock for shock's sake it's
all them
and it's all there and it unfurls and
unveils for you like
great art why the red napkins may i ask
i think we just pulled them out of a
shelf and then we've just been going
with red ever since
but when we started the show drew we did
not think these
things out all the way we were not like
oh color scheme like palette like
we were just uh just popping this thing
up and trying to make it happen
well i'm so glad you did
i feel really stupid because
i thought that maybe just maybe
that i was gonna be different
uh
i'm not hot sauce has a way of humbling
you
especially this one you know my daughter
actually olive
[Music]
gave me some tips actually
what are some of the tips she said
never stop chewing and fast be fast
smart girl um i also
noticed that it seems like people make a
mistake by licking their lips
so i'm trying not to do that
so i understand you have an endless
appetite for classic novels and credit
reading for inspiring your return to
hollywood after what you call
an unemployable hiatus do you have a
favorite literary easter egg from one of
your films
i read that the rabbit in donnie darko
was inspired by the rabbits in that
english novel
watership down that's a richard kelly
thing
um my literary easter egg was reading
still life with woodpecker by tom
robbins in 50 first dates
because lucy reads the same book every
day
i love that book
what's one stephen king book and one
stephen king movie everyone
should watch during quarantine
stand by me
oh my god
oh my gosh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
it's just draining out my nose is that
normal
is that how totally normal totally
normal drew i'm right here with you i'm
right here with you
scarlett said it's like giving birth but
i had c-section so i
i couldn't relate as queen of the
rom-com which novel would you pull off
the shelf for a hopeless romantic
a farewell to arms by ernest hemingway
be honest which piece of classic
literature is the most overrated
moby dick i'm having a hard time
processing
uh
never made it through moby dick and also
i'm like hesitant to crap on a literary
masterpiece
i'm dizzy is that that's normal right
how you feeling you want to move on you
want to chill for a sec yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it's down it's over what's the backstory
of appearing in sizza's music video for
drew barrymore it's kind of the perfect
cameo
well first i went through like a social
media channel
channel which everybody would do like i
don't know like hi
says that it's me i love you
and uh if i can ever do anything
uh one day that would please you or make
you happy will you let me know
and then she invited me to come do the
music video
and i showed up and i did i asked her
why did you name
the song with my name may i ask i'm not
in the lyrics
what was it that became the moniker for
it
and she really talked about that it was
a feeling and
something she related to and a feeling
she had
associated with me that was why she
wanted to name the song that
it's a real honor to be on anyone's
radar that you respect
period it's uh everything is
changing
well hold on drew we're almost at the
finish line
yes sean
all right drew barrymore this is the
last dab we call it the last dab because
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing
a little redundant here in these
quarantine episodes since everybody's
just dumping sauce all over wings but
here we are
and what a journey it's been drew it's
been it's been lovely spending the
afternoon with you i have to say
sean i honestly i am having a surreal
moment
that i would ever be on your and your
colleagues
radar because i oh
the sauce and talk it's it's tougher
than it looks you know this is
definitely the don't be a puss moment
wrong all right drew barrymore here we
are at the end of our spicy food
adventure and we've touched on your many
interests and films but to close things
out i want to talk about one thing
and one thing only and that is whales if
you ask me the most underrated project
on your storied resume
is big miracle a film about rescuing
whales in the arctic circle
so now with your brain on fire your
tongue ablaze
what do you find most special about
whales the barnacles on whales
is what i love because human beings have
scars and marks and life upon them
and when i see those barnacles on those
whales it reminds
me of wrinkles and life and how
beautiful it is to have these badges
all over your body of life
well you know what drew barrymore the
barnacles
they may stick to us the hot sauce it
may
challenge us but at the end of the day
we just keep moving
we just keep going we just keep swimming
and look at you drew barrymore taking on
some of the hottest vegan wings in the
history of the world
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you
this camera or this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
i'm so honored to say here on the hot
ones
with sean that i am
lucky enough to be doing a show yes it's
called the drewberry moore show but
it's a show and i want to have it be a
celebration of life
and explore and examine all of it and
have comedy
and i'm really excited for this
opportunity
so i guess that's what i came to plug
but i really came here to play
thank you thank you for having me great
job drew great job
on top of mount scoville drew flexing it
out
not wilbur scoville in 1912
[Laughter]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you